dafür ist eine kamera mit 90 millionen
theoretischen ja
[Musik]
ich darf hast dich sagen was ich sagen
soll ja nicht mehr einfach nur glück und
ich sind hier gerade auf song back to
school dreh mit spotify rennt ist maurer
kümmert sich in unserem podcast bei
spotify macht richtig beschissen
arbeiten
sondern du bist kein hund schon süß
durchgingen das habe ich nicht
verstanden
dass man so cdu ich hab hier williams 0
aber schon weg auch wieder optimal hier
pflanzen einfach selber tomaten an ich
hab auch mal tomaten angepflanzt bei mir
in hamburg in der wohnung und diese
sträucher sind einfach aus wie marihuana
dann kam die bundespolizei zu mir
welchen gremien hatten ja gesagt das
darf man nicht aber es war nur tomaten
[Musik]
jetzt wird erst mal geraucht so leute
wir müssen mal wieder hier promo machen
für die colo falls anders nicht nur 11
verhalten sie die letzten video auf
jeden fall machen sondern ich hier
gerade so ein back to school shooting
mit spotify weil sander und ich quasi so
mäßig zurück zur schule gehen wir müssen
aufgaben lösen auf eine witzige art und
weise und eigentlich brauchen wir
das hier sind die ekelhaften brötchen es
gibt also fünf kilo fleisch oder david
ich habe auch eine 5 kilo fleisch muss
aber eine hose
bio leistungskurs oder und du ich auch
luca nicht mal dann bat das macht es
mich in meine chicks film
ja du konsumschecks nagelt mich am boden
alles bild zum blau
das war korrektes deutsch glaub ich
einmal kurz applaus für david
jetzt hat er dinge zusammen waren das
timing muss fliegen
ich würde da stehen straßenschilder ich
sehe die nicht nur straßen stellen
können für das ja aber für e scooter
macht gleich steht davor wieder die das
intro
ja ich habe nichts was ist grün und
tötet durch wenn es vom baum fällt
delia tisch
ein lineal zurück sandra wir befinden
uns hier in der schule
was ist dein lieblings unserem podcast
die tecdax die trick dogs kein koffer
hatte untergewicht alle hatten
übergewicht das beschreibt meine familie
sehr gut weil wir alle setzen
also ich würde dem ganzen team konnten
geht das oft jedem
beendet
war in rage da oben wieder in übrigens
immer noch sehr weil nämlich haben wollt
dann nehmt mich doch einfach mal ohne
witz ich kann richtig gut
endlich sein dass ich jetzt schon seit
zwei jahren single bin
also nimmt mich doch jetzt mal was ist
sieben mal sieben und wird das ist
fünfmal fünf was ist sie geteilt sich
luca schlucken sandra
[Musik]
wenn die kamera wir müssen uns heute
gegenseitig malen
ich bin allergisch gegen teure
kunstwerke deswegen
niemand welches organ des menschlichen
körpers ist bezogen auf die oberfläche
des riffs nein ja die fans zu den drei
jetzigen von zehn
ich auch
kurze jetzt zusammen ausgegangen
auch immer halte ist umgezogen für
ständig noch darum nimmt dafür die
zinsen also die sache nicht ums geld
gegen selbst gemalt haben schreiben sie
kommentare ich schöner ist
das ist eigentlich das schöne ist das
übrigens die instanzen hin die am
größten fake ist und zwar hat die immer
im vorstand gesagt jetzt kauft sich
niemals gesagt bleiben letztlich schon
bald ihren taschen koffer sich unten
louis bacon tasche ja man denkt so von
außen braucht frische muss man so
richtig aufpassen sandra
weiss dass dieses buch beschreibt
sandersleben auch eins zu eins
tatsächlich
müssen ich grüße meine mutter und chris
laserdrucker
wir machen jetzt ins spiel und zwar
kennen das schon die podcast wir
versuchen jetzt raten was viele als
begrüßung sagt sara goller
[Musik]
sind sie mit zwei idioten am tisch ich
habe mich entwickelt
das ist das ein tiefer
sind jetzt bei mir und spielen monopoly
mit vierrad
sondern
mir
[Musik]
du bist gar draufgekommen vielleicht auf
die schlossallee wo zwei häuser drauf
stehen und das summa summarum
600 knoten in meine tasche sind
sandra ist der dino und ich habe diese
beiden straßen folge baut sie da
also bei mir sieht ziemlich rosig aus
ich hab fast alle straßen sandra will
den
leuten die situation zwei minuten später
das ist mit drei ist auf meine
schlossallee gekommen um an mittlerweile
sage und schreibe 1700 moneten in meine
tasche zeit ihr finales feedback zum
spiel
ich gebe nicht auf ich gehe nach hause
will dass wir das match morgen weiter
spiel das ist ein finales feedback ich
habe gewonnen
würde ich die glocke teil ist ob ich
mich freuen wenn es euch gefallen das
gerne einen daumen so unter dem video
nicht das kannst du das machen
das ist peinlich
einfach
so